I'm actually focused on this and I want to watch this guy, yes.
Being the strongest Counter-Points fan, okay? So, just a little
teaser. If you guys do want to donate more, if you want to try
to get more time on the stream, all
I'm locked in. >> with someone who says all Republicans
should fear for their lives in public. And you're going to criticize
me? >> 100% Connor disavowed that. How's he So, he says
I disavow but he works for >> Okay. Well, I say >> said
that he disavowed that that comment he made by >> Then
whatever you say whatever you say is bad about Donald Trump,
I'll just say I disavow but I still support him. Okay, now where
are we? What do you mean disavow or Okay, >> I I Watch.
Do you think there's a Do you think there's a difference
between Connor like associating with death Was that confusing?
>> city and supporting Donald Trump to be the president
of the United States? Like there might be a fundamental difference
between those two little >> Give me an example of
Um yeah, it should be
it should be way easier to to like disavow the person who you
have no like tie to, who the future of your kids aren't dependent
on, isn't dependent on.
Like realistically, you could think somebody's are totally morally
Listen, if there's somebody against Trump who's like totally
morally reprehensible,
maybe you might keep supporting them in some way, right?
Despite them being horrible people. And now your only response
is, "Well, that's what he's doing by helping Destiny." Oh, now
you're comparing Destiny and Trump yourself, are you? Something
like there might be a degree of separation. Now, hold on. Do
you think there might be a degree of separation between being
an associate of Destiny and supporting Donald Trump? Give me
an example of the United States. Yes, it's worse to actually
be in a business relationship with someone than to vote for someone.
Now, give me an example >> gosh, you're a I I answered
your
Like at least with Donald Trump, maybe Rob's got some argument
for how his principles like cut against one another. Counter-Points
is literally like money is my guiding light. That's that's the
argument Connor has to fall back to. question. Give me an example
Give me an example of something that Trump does that you thinks
anti-conservative.
Uh he betrays fiscal conservatism. He betrays uh promoting the
first first
>> I disavow. You disavow? >> Yeah, I disavow. What
about What is What is conservative that Trump >> I disavow
everything that Trump does that's not conservative. There you
go.
Okay, what the [__] are you talking >> I I
disavow everything that Trump does that's not conservative. Therefore,
how could I be What What What about Trump do you not disavow
then? I disavow the parts of him that aren't conservative and
I support the parts of him that are. What What about Okay, so
there's nothing about Dude, Rob is uh Rob is funny. I can't really
evaluate if he's winning or not right now, but he is funny at
least. >> that you like then. Thank you. Appreciate you
supporting my point.
>> Yeah, thank you for uh for saying you >> Hey, now
now great. Now, listen. I appreciate you Rob Noer for for the
>> you. I appreciate you making excuses and He's Hold on.
He understands that Rob is still going to vote for Trump, right?
That's the whole point is that if you disavow somebody, if you
say you disavow certain things they're doing, but those things
make no tangible difference in how you interact with that person,
you still do the exact thing that like you probably shouldn't
given the disavowal, then it's a meaningless disavowal that you're
only doing for optics and to try to maintain a little safe face.
in saying that actions are less important than words. That it's
okay to be in business relationships with people that say that
they want you and your family to fear for your
Do you understand? Is it possible Is it possible Is it possible
for you to be quiet while I'm talking? This guy is literally
coming at Rob with, "Um you voted for Donald Trump."
Um nothing counter Now, nothing Counter-Points has done is as
bad as you for voting for Donald Trump, okay? You You voted for
Donald Trump. I mean, if that's If that's your entire argument,
why'd you show up? talking and I'll be quiet while you're talking.
Is that possible? Be careful North. Because if you're going to
act like an ass I'm not acting like an [__] You came
That's why I'm going to act like an You came in spurking out.
You came in spurking out right out of the gate. Oh, yeah. I'm
the one that's spurking out.
Rob's using spurking out like a crutch right now, okay? You can't
You can't just Well, hold on. It's not about whether or not it's
evil, it's about you're having a discussion.
You'd want to argue it, right? If you're just going to say my
position is you voted for Donald Trump and therefore I don't
care about your criticisms, then you should have just said that
and not wasted anyone's time, right? Obviously. You are using
the the [__] debate tactics instead of actually trying
to What are you talking about? This has nothing to do with [__]
debate tactics. You're the one talking Look, I'm talking about
Donald Trump and whether he's a actual conservative or not. You
bring this over to Destiny. That's not what I You You said this
real loud.
I asked you You had to divert the point to something else. Like
I asked you You're too Okay, I asked you >> This is pathetic.
Is Trump a conservative? And then you can't even address the
point because you want to talk about Destiny. Yeah. I asked you
to give me an example of a real conservative. You picked Connor.
>> So, why would it be any >> Connor actually believes
in like a conservative value. And he holds the same conservative
values. I don't think he does. If he did, he wouldn't work with
a guy who said that he wants Republicans to fear for their lives.
I don't think that's conservative.
I don't Yeah, and your explanation
Hold on. Do you want me to get into the whole like [__]
Destiny argument like what do you mean? But >> Do you think
Donald Trump is
Please Rob, just say yes. Yes, explain to me how when when somebody
says, you know, I just want Republicans to fear for their lives
so they'll start putting pressure on Donald Trump. Explain to
me how that meant actually
Guys, what I actually meant there was we're in a realm we're
in like a a world where political violence is becoming normalized.
Shouldn't that scare all of us? That was actually the Guys, he
just meant like the opposite point of what he said, okay? Shut
the [__] up until this is done and then we can discuss
about it. No, he's not not He's promoting the idea He's promoting
the idea that he wants individual Republicans to be fearful unless
they stop voting for Donald Trump. >> idea that he's promoting
is that you can't say whatever the [__] you want
about the opposite party and not expect to like have some sort
of like fear of that happening to you. So, you can't say Oh,
so literally not the point Destiny was making at all, just some
new bespoke point that you've invented. Okay. Sorry, not not
his actual point, not his sweeping point that he came up with
after getting his ass his pushed in multiple times on the topic,
right? Neither of those, just some new bespoke thing you invented
out of nowhere. >> I want to go That guy That guy should
die. You can't say in public, "I think Mike Pence should be hung,"
you know? You should have a general fear of people doing that.
I don't think Democrats should have a fear of like Do you think
I will say it's a little up that I I grabbed this drama cuz I'm
like, "Cool, this is like This is drama in the debate sphere
that doesn't involve Destiny. I can like go off and just like
watch some other people and not have to deal with this in my
feed." And instead, it's just back to this guy, okay? This is
This entire sphere is like infected. It's kind of It's kind of
annoying sometimes, all right? >> Democrat should have
a fear of not saying like we need to hang Donald >> God
damn it, dude. >> Should Democrats have a fear of not saying
that we should Okay, should Democrats have a fear He's going
to do it again. Yeah. We need to Wait, what?
Democrats If some Democrat says something bad, I don't think
that every Democrat should fear for their lives to be in public.
You don't think they they should fear like like the the consequences
Amazing. the the their actions by saying
Wait, it's not them fearing for the It's Should Should anybody
have to fear that they're going to be harmed in public because
Donald Trump said a No. Because Donald Trump says things that
could push violence? No.
No, you shouldn't be responsible for somebody else's speech,
obviously. Jones said he wished death At least not held violently
responsible, >> He's running for AG. I'm not supporting
Let me finish. Let me
He's running for AG of Virginia. Not one
Would you please be quiet and let me talk? You sound like a petulant
child, right? Not one Democrat has refused to remove their endorsement.
If I said If I said, "Therefore, all Democrats should fear for
their lives to go in public," would you think that that's a fair
thing to say?
If they're endorsing what he says, I think they should have like
a a respectful fear if they're talking about saying like, "Oh,
yeah, this person should be like
What the [__] are these
Uh hold on. bringing it up. That's not what Destiny said. He
said all
They're like trying I I can tell what they're doing. They're
trying to avoid TOS violations, right? That's what they're trying
to avoid. But this is not helpful. Like meet the stream. Don't
Please stop just minimizing it. That That should be the crux
This should be everyone. Everyone should have a fear of what
they say in public. Pretty sure he just said correctly that >> what
Destiny said. Destiny said That is the the crux of Destiny's
argument.
Okay, so he he's kind of remembered what what Destiny says his
argument was a way after the fact after doubling and tripling
quadrupling down on just wanting Republicans to be afraid because
they won't denounce Donald Trump, right? He eventually got to,
"Guys, I think we should all have a healthy fear of political
violence and anyone who's not willing to totally disavow on both
sides, well, we should call that person into question."
Yeah, okay. But okay, hold on. Hold on. Do people see what I
mean? Rob Noer I came onto this debate panel to talk about Trump
and whether he's a conservative or not. And you will keep bringing
it back to Destiny. Like Okay, yes or no? Do you think Are we
at all good to
Are you going to just spurk out like the petulant child you are?
from the from the fundamental point that Donald Trump is not
conservative. He violates fiscal conservatism because he constantly
he's a raiser of taxes. He historic debt rises within the United
States. Like do we do we agree that he's not a fiscal conservative?
Do we agree that the first thing we need to do >> agree
that Trump is not I'm not going to ask you I'm not going to let
you spurk
What a These are incredible points.
Just Just listen.
Is there like some name for this thing right here? You're doing
You're doing this. What is this? What is this?
Who does Who do you think makes Who do
Who does this look good for? Who does this look good to? What
are we doing? I think I I think Counter Points should be Clockwork
Orange style forced to watch this this guy debate.
Uh with his eyes held open and realize what a young man following
him in Destiny looks like and then just reckon with that. Look
what you brought. Look at the destruction you have wrought, Counter
Points.
So his whole channel is like I I still like masculine content,
but it's not not like Andrew Tate, you know? Is that Is this
Is this where that gets >> Honestly, honestly I feel like
I would rather listen
Sneako Yeah, Sneako's way better than this guy. There's just
not even a comparison, okay? I take 1,000 Sneakos over this guy.
I'm sorry.
Listen, Connor's strongest soldier versus Andrew Tate's strongest
soldier, I take Andrew Tate's strongest soldier. That's That's
how it is.
By the way, this all started because these guys like had issues
with Rob. I don't know Were you watching this from the beginning?
Seeing these guys like on a panel Or sorry, they were on the
some stream late night like talking [__] about Rob's
stream, I guess. And his like previous crash out. >> I
couldn't I couldn't type because I was playing the game, but
the guy you're thinking of is Speakeasy.
Speakeasy is another guy who makes like a lot of money doing
those things. Yeah. Fair enough.
Is this guy like Soy Haz, by the way? Can we Can we dub this
guy like Soy Haz? He's got like the peaking mic, but he has like
no presence, okay? At least Haz had the energy. He had the presence.
This guy's peaking into his mic while like Soy Haz. This is like
This is like if
Non Fonz is Destiny
this is the Counter Points Non Fonz, if you know if you know
what I mean.
Um hold on. This guy's He's probably just way too jacked to be
that, okay? I'm so
Yes, I I actually can tell you what to do right now. Kicked from
the panel. Sounds like Rob won. I don't know about
Looks like you couldn't tell him what to do, bro.
I'm sorry.
He just gets right back in and starts yelling again.
Yeah, that's a perfect.
Yeah, it's pretty funny. I thought it was nice that he, you know,
as much as it was satire, he tracked like a lot of the core points
pretty well. Um shout out to Big Bun Yeah, shout out to Bun G
for knowing what the infinite rape machine was and knowing it's
like a thought experiment. Turns out that wouldn't have been
hard to look through, okay? You could have just watched a little
bit more of the VOD or been vaguely aware of the situation.
Sneako's Destiny by the follower all times. It's pretty funny.
He does. He does.
I did disavow a couple of comments though, okay? While laughing.
Like quite quite hard, you know? I totally disavow those comments.
Just a little gross. Couple couple What he did the poop sounds
over and over again for Destiny's app. The loot box. I was like,
you know, this Yeah, it was pretty up I'm going to say I'm I'm
just going to say it, okay? It's a little bit of homophobia.
Little [__] up to say.
Totally Totally disavow those comments. Do Do you get your disavowal
in? Do you disavow those comments? Yeah, I I also disavow when
he said uh if I were that didn't guess what I'd hate to say I'm
something went terribly
That's also I disavow that joke, too. I must miss that joke,
so
But luckily for us
I don't know. I just I must have missed that. Missed that one
entirely.
Economics, promoting lower taxes. Trump has violated all of this.
Mhm. All right, so So you can see you can see that your man Connor
that it was a reason that I was bringing up that I don't think
he's a very good conservative. I think he's a real conservative
cuz he actually cares about the [__] Constitution,
unlike you. I don't think he does. I don't think he does care
about the Constitution at all. No, I He does care about the
Uh
I need a picture of this guy in a coat walking with a clock in
the background as the nothing ever happens Chad, okay? I need
that stat.
Dude, the hair is Nobody I I always feel like I see that and
I'm like, nobody really has that hair, but he does. He's got
the hair. He's literally got it. You ready to go to fiscal conservatism?
Yes, please. Thank you. Okay. Who did you vote for that's a fiscal
conservative? I don't I I've said in the 2024
Presidential candidate for the Republican Party in the past two
decades you would have called fiscally conservative. I would
argue that there was probably none of them that were fiscally
conservative because just because they don't represent my values
doesn't mean that Okay, hold on. That value doesn't matter within
the Republican Party.
Wait, but what are you arguing for? So you're just going to abstain
from every election the past 20 years?
Oh, I didn't even know how I kind of thought like underneath
it all this guy's making like okay points and Rob was sort of
dodging, but Rob just kind of him brutally. Like, oh wait, so
you just wouldn't have voted in any of the last elections the
last 20 years. Right?
Yeah, they're all He's exactly the guy who moves out, gets his
trans girlfriend, and then dumps a significant conservative influencer.
This guy's got Tim Pool written all over his face and bedroom,
okay? It's not going to be good. Cancer on the Republican Party,
right? I would I would argue that the the way that they they
run as politicians is not representative of their conservative
ideas. No, and I want to change that,
>> So now the only conservative that You think Hold on.
I can just see it now. You think Counter Points has led to this
guy becoming like a Food Shops fan? You think Do you think we
can hold Counter Points responsible if this guy does get together
with Food Shops and dumps Tim Pool? I feel like I would blame
Counter Points directly.
Like Counter Points would have totally groomed him into becoming
a
Yeah, I think Counter Points would have like directly groomed
him into becoming a Food Shops fan. And then Yeah.
obviously. You've spoken positively of Wes Connor. Connor wants
to continue to spend billions of dollars in US aid. Is that fiscally
conservative?
Yes, this is This is Connor's biggest fan, yes. And
Rob just asked a fairly insane question,
Uh every time he the minor, he disavows the action and moves
on, okay? Conscience totally clear.
I I think Rob just framed like the US aid like cuts for Oh, is
it Is it vaccines or something? The thing that was basically
projected to kill a bunch of people. I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure Rob just cut like described that position as Connor wants
to spend a a ton of money in US aid.
How is that conservative?
Um I don't know if that's a good argument. I haven't looked into
that that whole argument going back and forth that Trump cut
a bunch of US aid that was going to like medical relief for people.
But I believe that's what Rob just characterized as Connor just
wants to spend a a ton of money. Donald Trump has increased the
national debt to historic highs. Would you call that fiscally
conservative? >> No, I don't. I think I criticize Trump
for not being fiscally conservative. >> Okay, then thank
you. So you agree with me that Donald Trump is not fiscally >> So
I again, when you're talking your statement wasn't just I think
that Donald Trump's not fiscally conservative. Your statement
had to do with a cancer on the Republican Party. So far you've
said so far you I think populism was To be clear, when I say
a cancer within the Republican Party, I mean populism. We have
allowed populism to enter the Republican Shut the [__]
up while I'm talking.
Yeah, are you going to try to stop sperging out? Populism we
have allowed within the Republican Party is a cancer. Shut up.
He's the leader of the populist element of the Republican Party.
We need to purge that from the Republican Party. Now, what you
said was that it was a cancer that I and Trump were cancer. All
right, what you said was that Trump and I What you said was that
Trump and I were a cancer on the Republican Party. The first
area you have got to was fiscally conservative. You have officially
admitted that no I feel like Rob could just turn him down slightly
if he doesn't want to get cut off by the peeking mic. I don't
think he has to like actually move him out. >> one in the
Republican Party that has ran for president is a fiscal conservative.
The only word conservative that you've identified positively
is Connor. Is that what Brianna Wu was doing to you, showing
dominance?
Well, I think it moved out. I was getting muted.
I don't know. I actually don't I have no idea how to StreamYard.
I don't think I've ever been in a StreamYard before. So, EG.
I've directly said that he's clearly not fiscally conservative
as he wants to spend billions in USAID. You have no response.
Jerome Powell, Mitt Romney, Thomas Massie. I mean, what do what
the [__] do you want me to say? Mitt Romney of RomneyCare?
They never voted They were all in the Senate and other places
where they voted for budgets that were not fiscally
Look, okay, what do you mean what I say fiscally conservative?
I would say fiscally conservative means balanced budgets, cutting
spending. Yes. >> Okay, did Mitt Romney vote for budgets
that weren't balanced budgets?
No, Adam and Sitchu Zoom. Weren't You were on there with me,
Cherry. You don't remember that they use Zoom?
We use Zoom for that [__] Which is even worse than
whatever StreamYard is. I've never used StreamYard, but Zoom
is by far the worst thing you could possibly do to have a political
conversation or have a conversation on the internet of any
Zoom is just cancer in every way. That was I Thank you for reminding
me of the most horrible experience of my entire streaming career,
Cherry, having to get Zoom set up. Microsoft Teams is
Only because you have to have Microsoft Teams installed.
But I don't know. Zoom is somehow more infuriating to me. It's
terrible. The Donald Trump >> do that? >> Yes. So,
if you can criticize Mitt Romney for not having that, would you
criticize Donald Trump for having that? >> Yes. Okay, then
thank you. We agree.
So, what you're trying to say is that there is a cancer in the
Republican Party for someone like Trump. What I'm saying is this
is pretty much ubiquitous with all Republicans.
And so, to say that this would be cancerous for Trump, the very
first issue you talked about where it's something that all Republicans
would do seems to belie your point. If almost all Republicans
are one thing and you say that that's a cancer on almost all
of them, and then you continue to support a person who also is
not a fiscal conservative as the metric that we should stand
up for, that seems nonsensical. It seems that either A, you shouldn't
have picked Connor as the person that you said is a conservative,
or B, you should have chose a better starting point than fiscal
conservatism when you can't give me one example of one fiscal
conservative.
Okay, do you think that the part the Wait, wait, wait. Before
we continue on with this, um what was your take on Emiru?
You think Think Twitch is done? Think it's over for Twitch? Oh,
you just cut out. I just right.
No, it's obviously not over Twitch.
Anyone saying that is legitimately mentally disabled.
I think I think Dan Clancy's got to go down, okay? Did you not
hear that when Dan Clancy heard about
He literally bought a round of drinks when he heard about it.
And he He heard about it. He bought a round of drinks for the
entire bar to celebrate, okay?
It's [__] How can you not think it's over and you
know about this? >> Yes, Emiru Emiru has been deflowered.
Her innocence has been taken. As we all know, she's a virgin.
Double kisses
She's been She's been deflowered
in front of everyone. Yes. Yes. Let's drink to this. That was
Dan Clancy.
That was Dan Clancy, okay? Dancing Clancy. He set it up. Osama
bin Clancy.
Terrible stuff.
Spider posted a clip of himself on Twitter. Hold on. From the
whatever this review us. Didn't like Didn't like me getting called
out here, okay?
Didn't Lav Loon make false allegation He's He really trying to
cook right here? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Didn't Lav Loon make
false allegations about Ha- HasanAbi, implying he slept with
a 17-year-old? Why is he still in your community? I actually
don't know that those are necessarily false, okay? I've not done
the math there. I don't know how to do the math there.
and she's funny.
Why is this Kayla loser doing [__] tweets? Go on
a [__] cool leave,
He could just jump in if he wanted. You probably should have
called out Lunar Box in DMs or something for not stepping in
when Lawson started No, I'm totally fine calling him out in public.
Why Wouldn't that just be kind of [__] if I watched
that, just said nothing, looked like a in front of my stream,
and then messaged him privately to be like, "I'd appreciate next
time you correct the record on this." I've actually asked him
to correct the record on [__] like this
I don't I just don't like being lied about, and I feel like if
I have a reasonable rapport with somebody, when someone makes
a totally baseless allegation against me, then you know, somebody
could go, "Hey, that's baseless. We should probably You know,
you should probably have some evidence for that." bad.
Uh I think he's like black. I think he's like uh
He's like some kind of Mediterranean.
He's like Indian, sweaty fellow.
He's like Indian. If that's what you think, that's what you think.
Just because him and Saurus are both are both of Lunar Box's
editors, okay? Doesn't mean you can connect them. That's a crazy
connection to make, okay? You're just going to say all Lunar
Box editors are Indian? It's kind of [__]
Wouldn't surprise me. Is that why Is that why Lunar Box had to
get rid of Weppy? Got rid of Weppy, hired two Indians?
Yeah, no no no whites. They ask too much high wage. This This
white guy actually This sweatshop vibes off of this white guy.
Like cool center vibes off of this
Major cool center vibes off of this guy. I don't I don't mind
Spider, but Jesus. Every time I see him posting somewhere, he's
like mad disabled.
He seems like No, he's got There's something there. There's something
there.
I I see him on like Lunar Box's stream once in a while, and it's
like I I can tell he's like black or something cuz he's saying
the N- and like
you know, it seems like he's not I've not heard him talk for
more like 20 seconds at a time. But he doesn't seem like he's
like
He doesn't really say much. But then you see him type, and you
see him talking in other places, and it's like, "Wow, this guy's
like
got mental issue or something. This guy's like actually disabled."
And he behaves like mad disabled, too, just like posting
like these gay football GIFs and like messaging people
He might be like 17 or something. He's like a Listen, young people
are actually mentally disabled, okay? If he's like that young,
I could get I could see it.
If he's like 25,
That would make sense. If he was 17, I would understand why he
would make sense why he seems Indian. Let's see here. What else
did he say?
Well, maybe Well, hold on. Maybe I could have pushed back more,
but I did press Dan when he started wrongly grouping Hasan in
with the brothel stuff. I don't care. I'm not I'm not Hasan.
I don't give a [__] about Hasan's reputation. Lie
about Hasan all you like.
Go to fame Hasan as much as you like in other places. I hear
them defame If I hear you defame him on my stream, I might go,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa. Where's the evidence for that, okay?" That's
the
I actually should
That's totally insane. That's completely [__] insane.
I'm sorry cuz I I talked to Emiru. I was watching a clip of her.
She was like asking me if something going on in the stream or
something. And I was like, "Oh, would Lunar Box have pushed back
against that? You would have said something, right?" She's like,
"Yeah, I did." She's like, "I said something in chat, so he pushed
back against that." And haven't heard any push back at all.
Hopefully he sees her chatting right now and says something.
I would post a minute long clip in a five paragraph tweet. Dude,
brevity is the soul of wit, okay? Um
He had to get all the @s in, okay? By the way, Spider, you @
this many people, they won't see the tweet.
So, you know. Or sorry, this won't like blow up. Here, I'll even
I'll try to help you. Put a like on it. Boom.
Okay. Anyway, I can't remember why I even clicked over onto that.
Irrelevant.
Okay, we continue.
Oh, we were talking about Emiru. Right. We were talking about
Emiru. Hold on.
Yeah, we'll get into it a little a little bit later. Have you
followed any of the news?
The the It has security guards and the idea that The idea that
favorite security guard could ban two years ago. My favorite
security guard could ban two years ago. That's just a right It's
so stupid. It's irrelevant. Yes, if your security guard puts
hands on someone, even if they're in the right, they're probably
going to get banned from an event for the sake of the the liability
of the company that runs it. That's what I That's totally what
I said. It's They probably had to get rid of them for liability.
Any com- any company, anywhere, always going to be the case.
It's why every every store and every place any security or loss
prevention they hire, they'll tell them, you know, don't [__]
chase them. Don't [__] tackle people. Don't [__]
hold them. Because obviously the liability's on the place. And
you don't want a paper trail of like history of a certain security
guard having physical incidents. Something happens in the future,
and then that can be pointed to in litigation. So, there's so
many [__] reasons why you don't want this to be the
case, and that's why this is obviously the case. And the idea
that you as a
Okay, okay. Hold on. You you are a
world-famous brand. You you are a celebrity. The idea that my
favorite security favorite security guard No, hire new security
that can do the [__] job. Nobody can see themselves
that way, but it just real quick on the insurance point. I think
it's like really like on Twitch's part. How is Twitch not just
come out and say this? That's not giving anything away. It doesn't
make anybody less safe. Just say, "Hey, yeah, this happened.
Obviously it would be a liability issue to keep them. We had
to ask that we had to ban them from the show." Like they don't
come out and defend themselves at all. They don't say anything
that could help people. And also, they let a bunch of like weird
narratives go. Like a bunch of people think that that private
security guard was Twitch security,
right? Being late to help her out. Like people think that actually
what happened there was all private security was banned from
Emiru. Emiru couldn't have private security anymore. That's how
a bunch of people have received these tweets. I'm sure because
if I go back and look, Tech Tone and a bunch of other probably
just totally lied about it off the bat, got it wrong, and never
really corrected. So Yeah, most of the people I've seen have
been saying favorite security guard specifically. Well But even
that's probably it. And they had it has been
Even just that is like the idea that that's just a insignificant
thing that 2 years ago your favorite security guard was banned.
Well, okay, you should be able to figure that out in 2 years.
I mean, you make literally millions of dollars. Hire two Hire
two security guards. Surely two could compete for what that one
guy did. >> Yeah, you really you could you couldn't you
couldn't have a security guard both both sides?
You couldn't have like is this like too much to ask? Is this
like too much to
Jack Doherty just finds like a huge black fellow security guard
that can knock somebody out and like literally will go to jail
for him. Yeah, there you go. Cash to just a huge black criminal
and just like damn man, I used to look after me for the day.
It It just works, okay? You saw that guy talking [__]
to him in front of It's a
It's in front of the What was it? Like the couple There was a
couple stars at some party and some dude started talking [__]
to Jack Doherty and this black dude just walks up and whops this
guy in the face. I've never seen somebody get hit harder in my
entire life. Like, okay, yeah. Why didn't Emiru could be protected,
okay?
Did you see the veto tweet? No.
Um some weirder tried to hug her and was immediately stopped
by security. How much drama can you possibly milk out of this
nothing story? That's so unreal. Oh my god.
That's facts, like that's facts. And literally like a whole drama
cycle about Emiru not getting ripped. Like yo, I was okay. Dude,
he almost kissed her, okay? He almost kissed her. Did he grope
her? No, but like he almost kissed her.
It's right there.
He was not a felon beforehand. I'm telling you you you should
get a felon that is like they've experienced the inside and they're
not afraid of it and they're willing to go back as long as you
pay them hazard pay or something, okay? That's the kind of person
you should get. That's the That's the vibe. That's the aura you
should cultivate, okay? As Emiru. Watch one of these freaks try
something after one of them gets like knocked out cold and wakes
up with their brain scrambled, okay? The next day. I still say
he took out a knife. Really quick. People Are people really still
saying he took out a knife? >> No, I think I've seen most
people correct that to a pen. >> Well, that person saying
that should be all right then.
Yeah, he took out a knife after the man stopped him. No, that
Yeah, sorry, this person's Just not what happened. Just just
not what happened. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Do you have a non-unhinged
take on this? I feel like I understand Emiru being upset, but
I don't understand the like
necessarily calls on Dan Clancy to resign for this again.
Yeah, the the calls for Dan Clancy to resign makes no sense.
I guess it's kind of bad that Twitch didn't check up on her.
Like, you know, you'd expect people to be checked up on after
incidents like that and for
And she's I guess Emiru's claiming that they didn't ask extra
Emiru if she wanted extra security the next day.
So, or extra Emiru could have fallen victim to not getting ripped
as well. Wait, but did they just give Emily more
Like What if they just gave her more
Yeah, I don't know.
Well, I don't I I feel like it's kind of incongruent with that
what Dan Clancy said to Tyler Renz cuz he said to Tyler Renz
like we'll walk him with grace
uh to make sure they've got the security they need and that doesn't
seem to be particularly true. I did think his response was like
kind of I feel like
Like could you imagine if after 9/11 George Bush came out and
said like the TSA do a fantastic job, they're world class, they
don't [__] this up, right? It's like Yeah, 9/11 just
happened, bro. How about you like say, you know, we [__]
up or something. Um maybe not if you don't want to take liability,
but it's like don't come out and say you're world class. I don't
know, it feels really And this is like the 9/11 of Twitch, I
It is the 9/11 of Twitch. Wait, hold on. It is absolutely the
9/11 of Twitch. Em Emiru defiled. Are you serious? The queen
herself? It was one thing when there were rumors of Miskif doing
it, okay? But this guy
This guy was just an ape, a random ape off the street.
Also, did you notice that you know who's the most victimized
in all of this
I think honestly every OTK girl should be put in a club, but
I don't know who's who's the most victimized. Jesus Christ.
It's the blue-haired guy.
The blue-haired guy who's standing beside her. He'll forever
He'll forever know what it's like to have had his one chance
with Emiru. He would have no chance ever, but if he'd managed
to stop this or push this guy back or do anything, okay? He had
a 0.001%
chance down from like negative infinity or up from negative infinity
and he fumbled it, okay? He had his one shot to make all of his
dreams come true. >> That that like anime moment, you know,
where that where they stop where time where they stop in time
as like that the guy just moves past >> He could have been
like DaBaby, okay? With Arena. He could have been like DaBaby,
all right? He could have stepped right in there, grabbed this
guy's hand. Everything just goes black around this guy. He's
just like frozen. This guy is just like slowly walking past.
He can't do anything. What Emiru? What Emiru? Hey Emmy. He watched.
He just He watched like a the whole time.
Oh, no, sorry.
He pretended he couldn't see it. He He opted for the stick to
play, okay? Yeah, he couldn't maintain eye contact. Is What's
happening here is he getting ready to do a photo with her?
>> And so he's like standing there looking forward and
doesn't realize that she's been like taken out basically. Yes.
Oh, dude, he's so He's so slow to react to her screaming, too.
Oh my goodness.
The guy is like at least the security guard's there.
Okay, but like this security guard that was not on on the gate
on ball at all, right? He was like totally [__] up
here. No, if this guy was like a deranged K-pop fan, okay? With
a knife, Emiru is done. Emiru is done. Attack you dinner. She'd
be sushi right now, okay? It'd be
She'd be sushi, yeah. Yeah, sashimi specifically.
I posted this earlier, but the blue-haired guy is Spider-Man
failing the QTE to save the Yeah, he did fail the quick time
event. Hold on. Apparently he's a Spider-Man quick time event
here. Is this really You just hit space bar? Help, please. Someone?
Oh, this is Emiru, yeah. I'm going to die. Okay, I've never I've
I've never seen that before.
That's amazing. Jesus. Oh man. Hold on. Hold on. Where are we?
We're here. Yeah, this security guard is totally He's just leaning
against the wall. Yeah. Like he's leaning against the wall around
doing nothing. This guy like walks past
It's like you're not If a guy just like storms past you going
straight towards the person you're meant to be looking after,
do you not just like immediately start walking forward like tailing
a little bit?
Is that not You probably do, but he's he's clearly distracted,
right? If you go back further, if I grab the Twitch file of this,
right? I can't remember what the guy's name was from the Twitch
file, but I'll find it 2 seconds. Um if you go backwards on this
through the Twitch file, it's like pretty clear he's having a
discussion with the manager directly and he's distracted. Which
is probably really bad for his
But he is literally talking to the manager while this happens.
Let me find this uh vod really quickly. Here's this It just doesn't
make like any sense anyone's decisions here. Well, it does make
sense if you just assume that everyone here is like a
So, he's standing here. I think you see him lean over to talk
to the person.
We'll We'll keep watching him. We'll see if it changes. Oh, hold
on.
I mean, he seems to be watching there. Oh, hold on. No, do you
see his head go right here? Do you see this guy walking forward
and then
I'm trying to see if you see his head twist around at all. As
this guy is walking through
Oh, you don't see anything.
This guy is like standing there looking at the wall. Like that
he's got This guy is actually This guy could have like a a blade
in Emiru's throat right now and this security guard is still
leaning against the wall. Well, that's crazy.
I don't know how they did this event and they didn't just rope
all the way to the back here, right? I don't know how they had
like a >> none of it makes any sense. I don't understand
how this guy just like walked through and can walk back out.
Like why why have you got these little barriers up these little
like uh you know, ribbon barrier things up if you don't have
them go all the way around?
Yeah, or or at least have someone at like the each of the openings
you would like security at least someone watching it. Like I
I None of it makes any sense. Like what what is anyone doing
this whole time? Including Emiru's security cuz it's so gay that
It's all Twitch is for all Twitch for Absolutely. Whoever the
Twitch security guards are that were here, it sounds like based
on what Emiru said, they were like just [__] around
talking. Yeah, they're incompetent 100%. So is Emiru's security
guard. Cuz I mean, you can watch this and he's like distracted
and doesn't act.
And I understand him wanting to go make sure she's like taking
care of, but I also feel like
I don't know. There's like a snap decision where he follows the
guy for a second and then he comes back to Emiru. And I get that
Emiru is paying him, but it's like
But do you think this is like a coordinated attack on Emiru?
Like
I feel like he could have gone and followed the guy. >> That
guy is the threat. You should probably keep an eye on that guy.
Like make sure he's dealt with and he's arrested for trying to
do that, basically. See So, he goes he walks him out. >> And
then he stops there and goes back. It's like I mean, I guess
if you want to go back grab him until Twitch security comes and
then hand him off and then go back, I would think.
Well, not even grab him because I mean I I thought he's supposed
to grab anyone really. I mean, he's already kind of you know,
once grabbing after you shoved the guy really. Um But he should
definitely obviously follow him, right? He should be following
him, be on the on the phone to I assume they've got contact with
security there or something.
Well, that's what you think, right? Like I'm following this guy
he's around here, do you know? Keeping an eye and making sure
he gets grabbed or you've got at least ideally him. >> Yeah,
I feel like I feel like when you're private security like that
I think you get a little bit once they once they've grabbed like
the person you're protecting, I think you're willing to get banned
from the event.
I feel like you should that's kind of like You probably should
be, yeah. I mean, the here's the thing is that he shoved him
already, so like like you know, what is grabbing at that point?
Like you've already you've already done it, you know, grab the
guy, right? To make sure it's safe. Cuz you you've already taken
that that you've already crossed that barrier. >> already
yeah, you've already hurt him or you've already I guess technically
assaulted him. >> Yeah, and then and then and then, yeah.
Uh this is I was kind of thinking this in compar- thinking of
this in comparison to organized retail theft. I'm guessing the
reason the security can't grab people and the reason they don't
want private security doing it is the exact same thing like you
said. Uh liability and just not wanting to be held liable for
any of this and it's like the same reason in California that
you get all the organized retail theft where they just say no,
no, no, don't even stop them. Like you literally don't do anything.
Cuz somebody was saying, oh, if he commits a felony, can't you
like apprehend him? And it's like, well, what proof do you even
have that he committed a felony? Do we know that grabbing him
by his cheeks is a felony? Like it's probably some kind of assault,
but is it felony assault or is it a misdemeanor?
Like I don't even know.
I I don't know and I'm I'm just guessing all of these huge clothing
chains don't say let the guy go because they're just being like
what, you know, massively cautious. It's probably like a real
worry that you could get in like actual trouble for trying to
stop people commit petty crimes. In California, it's a misdemeanor
from what I've read. Aggravated assault would be a felony.
Well, if California knows Listen, if Gavin Newsom knows what's
good for him, it'll this guy will get the electric chair, okay?
That's all I'm saying. That's what I'm saying Ethan Ralph called
the Legal Mindset Breakdown video
And Ethan Ralph's like uh saying he doesn't want to see Legal
Mindset in a shock collar, he wants to see him in an electric
chair and all this [__] Dude, the Legal Mindset video
I don't think some people are like, oh, this is clearly satire.
I'm pretty confident it's not satire. >> not satire. It's
not satire. It's either grifting or mental or like mental illness
mental breakdown. I don't see how it could be grifting with like
the Antifa section and him describing like what constitutes him
being stalked. Like like I understand he's grifting as well,
but I don't see how grifting could be like the reason for including
all of that alone. Like it he's pretty good in how he grifts.
Like he's pretty smart in the decisions he makes to grift. Like
with how he decides what side to take in any given like legal
thing.
He's he's been pretty accurate. He's grown his channel pretty
fast.
I don't know. Like if he had He's just doing 100
This is the new gr- This is the new grift now. This is what it
is it's a cuckism. It's saying I'm a mod of Christianity. I'm
going to
There's no way that could work for very long, right? But he's
nice, man. I feel like if you have
just an entire library of content that implies that you don't
believe in any of the values of Christianity at all, then you
should be like totally prohibited, okay? Like there should be
a state >> way that you would say this guy's a gym walker
as well. This guy he's like there's a lot of Mecca jokes and
all this [__] He always makes Mecca
And and Mr. Mecca decided he was a Christian after
after Charlie Kirk got shot. Wait, uh
you know, it all just lines up. It's all just part of the same
cuckism
grift. I heard I Wait, had Nux come out as religious recently,
too? Did he do the same thing?
Well, Nux is
I know. That's why I said religious, not Christian. He was doing
some trad thing, wasn't he?
Like he was basically like oh, he was denouncing gooning. That's
what it was. Which is like literally from what, 2010 to 2023,
his entire brand was gooning and now he's like, guys degeneracy
is wrong. Isn't that direction he's going? I haven't been looking
into the content. >> Basically, yeah.
He said people in the CDC should be hanged for vaccine mandates.
Dude, what [__] That's vile, okay? That's that's
That's [__] up. They need more of like the existential
dread. You know, the anime existential dread drawn into this
guy's face, the lines, the vertical lines kind of losing all
color. Need that as Bro, this picture might exist, actually,
right?
The person was taking the picture, the one event worker had his
phone had this blue-haired guy's phone. This photo may literally
exist. >> She took the pictures. Do you think she just
went ahead with it and took the pictures or what? >> if
she did What if she did like a live photo, right? Like the the
iPhone has like the live photo thing, so you get like all the
different angles over time. What if she got a live photo right
as this guy came in and there's like frames of yeah, that exact
picture.
So, you get like the flipbook version of Amouranth to Twitch
Con.
Dude, imagine he's like smiling. God, what was the Dan Clancy
paid him to do it stuff earlier? We're mocking everybody who's
like Dan Clancy's got to go and saying implying that Dan Clancy's
like celebrating this happening and
you know. >> she paid this guy. He paid this guy and he
told the security to stand down and let him through.
He said Amouranth will be today. >> If you if you look
at photos of the convention center from before anybody got here,
they actually had the ropes all the way along here, okay? All
the way to the back. And Dan Clancy told them take those down.
No, they're too expensive, put them back away.
They can't afford it. Let me see here.
Ah, [__] Okay, I think
I do kind of want to finish some of this Rob stuff. I don't know
if it's going to be Rob versus this guy for a lot longer. Let
me see.
This guy is a total loser. >> like, you know, sperg he's
not like a
You know, yeah, this guy's awesome, actually. This guy's awesome.
I wasn't going to call this guy a sperg, but this guy's awesome.
How many how many links do you need to call somebody a like a
supporter if they support a supporter? Like how many times how
what's the >> This guy This guy is a Destiny fan, too,
bro. This guy's a Destiny fan, too.
I want to say I remember somebody sent me one of those things.
You know when Counter-Points was like doing one of his sweeping
streams? I want to say this is one of the guys who's like really
mad in chat about people asking questions.
If I remember it. Oh, really? I think this is one of those guys.
Someone's asking questions about Destiny drama. I won't go back
to Counter-Points talking about politics. He would read off of
ChatGPT on the second one of Well, he's on talking on the phone.
I want to see what developments come between the ages of 15 and
16 today, Counter. Can you write that out for me? Guys, can you
shut the [__] up? Connor is doing his development
chart. Republican base supports fiscal conservatism?
N- No. No? So, do you think that that fiscal conservatism is
at all part of like the Republican Party? It is something that
they've talked about, but I think that the base is >> the
Republican Party should strive for fiscal conservatism? Yes.
Do what But that's not the >> that? Listen. But do you
hold on. Listen, it's not that this isn't Listen, listen, shut
the [__] up, dude. This isn't you ask me 500 questions.
I respond to your question, I let you talk, right? And Squid
broke law, then you respond to me or let me finish my answer
then other just short yes or nos, right? Now, But the point that
I'm trying to make the point What do you mean I'm not let It's
not that I'm not Dude, this guy sold this thing. Right? Now,
the point that I'm trying to make the only way What do you mean
I'm not It's not that I'm not letting you talk. You asked a Bro,
I
There's something There's something going on with like the speech
patterns here that
like I do think this guy could easily be in like a special education
like have some kind of learning disability. It's something about
like he like breathes in before he starts talking.
Dude, you're not even letting me talk. You know you know why
this guy Connor?
Why is that? This guy this guy 20 years ago would have been in
the Marines. Could he wouldn't he wash out? The [__]
I don't even Really? You think out of um Yeah, well,
you know, these these people play video games 16 hours a day
now. That's why I said 20 20 years ago. Oh, I see.
You know, 20 years ago this guy's parents were you know, now
sitting there around with an American flag up playing video games,
Warhammer.
You know, watching other Counter-Points. 20 years ago it would
have been, why don't you join the military? Why don't you join
the military?
Through Pavlu complaining about Haz al-Din being the downfall
of the West when realistically we're looking at it on our screen
right now, okay?
The point that I'm trying to make the only way What do you mean
I'm not let It's not that I'm not letting you talk. You asked
a question. You said, does the base support fiscal conservatism?
I said, no. You didn't you skipped right over it without saying
whether you agree or disagree that. The in- the implicit argument
that you're trying to make there is the base supports fiscal
conservatism. The reason I say no that I don't think it does
is because we've never voted for a fiscal conservatism. In fact,
Donald Trump clearly right now has the majority of the support
from the Republican base. It does not seem that they rejected
him after he wasn't fiscally conservative in his first term when
they proceeded to vote for him in both the attempt in 2020 election
and in 2024. So, no, I don't think the majority of the base supports
fiscal conservatism. I do. I supported someone like Ron Paul.
I didn't support someone like Connor who wants to spend billions
of dollars in USAID. That's what you did. I think you're a fake
fiscal conservative.
Well, I would argue that the the USAID thing is about neoconservatism.
But go hold on. Do you find it ridiculous that the fact that
the only way that you're able to actually like neoconservatism
and then he's when your argument is by just constantly muting
me instead of letting me actually talk. No, I think you're spurting
out and not letting me talk and you're demanding that you be
allowed to spurt out over me. Actually making a real point, you're
just muting me and preventing me from That's not true. I've given
you a chance to talk. That's not true. What it is What it is
is you spurt out the whole time and you're trying to filibuster
and not let me talk. So I had no choice after watching you do
that. I'm making actual points. making a point. Okay, then I'll
ask you the question. Are the Is the Republican base fiscally
I would say that they they should strive for fiscal conservative.
That's not the question. It's not should, it's is. Are they?
Yeah, the voter base yes, the politicians No. Then why then why
haven't they voted for the actual Republicans that are fiscally
Because they're the voter base currently is being right now.
We need to hold our politicians more accountable. That is
I don't even think that's true. I think they all they all talk
about being fiscally fiscally conservative, but there's literally
nobody who's voting for it. You could say they're being but literally
your vote is your preference.
You can't say they're and they're voting against their preference.
Their vote is their preference. What I'm I'm advocating for.
That So I just want to be clear. Your argument are not showing
our conservative values that we should be voting them out. So
I just want to be clear. Your argument is that base is fiscally
conservative, they're just
They're they're betraying their ideals for the sake of winning.
Yes. So they the own Republican base is pretending to not be
fiscally conservative to win, but they really are. That's your
argument. They're pretending they're willing to violate their
values in order to win an election. This is my criticism of the
Donald Trump and the Republican populism within the Republican
Party. Is that we have abandoned every single one of our conservative
values for the sake of winning an election. You just The one
conservative you could claim that you support is someone who's
not fiscally conservative and that's Connor. When I ask you to
name more, you said people like Mitt Romney who also aren't fiscally
When I ask you for actual politicians, you said people like Mitt
Romney who also aren't fiscally See, this is what I'm talking
about. So we'll do When I ask you to name politicians, you said
people like Mitt Romney who also you concede aren't fiscally
conservative. So therefore you're stupid and you're subverting
your values because the Republicans in office you're claiming
to support to win are people themselves that aren't fiscally
conservative. Can you explain to me why you're willing to sell
out your values to support these non-fiscally conservative Republicans?
You're the one selling out your values for supporting people
like Donald Trump. You have admitted that Donald Trump is not
a fiscal conservative and yet you are still in support of him.
Is Rob like a turbo Is he Does never struck me as a fiscal conservative.
He struck me as like a through and through populist the whole
time.
I've never heard him go and talk about how like oh these budgetary
concerns are really with me. Never once heard him talk about
it. Maybe he defines himself that way, but I've never heard him
talk about it at all.
Rob is like
he is like the Republican that gets dragged along with Trump.
That's what I feel like, you know. He's he's he's always talking
about populism because he's always defending
But you know, if he could just if he could just remake
what's happening in in his image, it would be
maybe more Ron Paul. I don't know about that. I've never heard
him talk like political philosophy, but I've only ever seen him
just be out and out supporting Trump. And I've heard the basis
for this a couple times and I thought it was the 2016 election
and how Crossfire Hurricane went. Like how they tried to slander
Trump basically. I thought he went from that point to say but
basically became like a populist. He thought like all the institutions
were rotting because of like an actual deep state. And so he
just to find himself in opposition to that from that point moving
forward.
So I I feel like I've heard him say that like the deep state
like the deep state
Department of Justice, I think specifically
was the thing he was like most concerned about the US. I'm I'm
almost positive which is why you had the whole focus on the Hillary
emails, Hunter Biden
and the double standard for prosecutions. I think that's like
what his general thoughts were. That's what I remember of him
from debates and but I certainly am not an
Rob broke in here.
All right, so what I'll say is
Do you admit that you are
All right, so what I'll say is that I fully admitted that I think
one of the things I criticized Donald Trump for is that he's
not fiscally conservative or that he's a screech that that he
is a cancer in the party or that people that don't vote for fiscal
conservatives are violating their conservative values. That's
what you have done. I have never said that about you. I wouldn't
say oh you Mitt Romney voters, you're not real fiscal conservatives.
Why I myself am voting for Donald Trump who also isn't fiscally
conservative. So you actually have this backwards. Your criticism
of me is I am selling out because I support someone like Donald
Trump who isn't fiscally conservative while you yourself are
supporting people that aren't fiscally conservative, but you
don't consider yourself a sellout. I never said you were a sellout
for voting for someone or supporting someone that wasn't fiscally
conservative. That's your argument and you are being hypocritical
by doing the very thing you're accusing me of. I'm not being
saying that giving up USAID is a bad
It's not just that.
Dude, this guy just keeps yelling at the same boomer who keeps
cutting in and talking over these two.
I don't know if it's something about his mustache. Shut up. You're
making me think you're wrong all along to the members. Well,
yeah, but I support them for different reasons. I support them
because they have actual principles that they're willing to stand
on and they're willing to not bend to the party just because
that's what like Donald Trump says. Like So you're willing to
sell out your fiscal conservative principles.
I'm willing to support politicians who actually have a backbone.
No, no, no, that's a different question. You said that if a Republican
is selling out their principles to win, if they're supporting
a Republican that's not fiscally conservative. And that's exactly
what you're doing. It's a bad thing. Yes, when Republicans do
that. It's a bad thing. That's what you do too though, right?
No, it's not what I do. Okay, so then who's the politician you're
supporting?
Who's the politician you're supporting? You said Mitt Romney.
Spider posted in the gen chat. Within 60 seconds I asked him
if he wanted to hop on stream. He's gone silent for the past
5 minutes.
I'm lucky.
Well, not because of his fiscal conservatism. So you're willing
to So the one politician you could name isn't a fiscal conservative,
but you support them. So can you explain to me why you're selling
out your conservative
Well, you're
I expected much less from this debate, but you're just an actual
just I am assuming you did expect too much less. You didn't expect
anything I expected you to actually address my points. I am addressing
your point. What you want to do is say this. I think you're uniquely
a cancer because I have definitions that I think are conservative
and I think you're voting for a guy that doesn't meet those.
The first of those I have is fiscally conservative. Of course,
I myself also support Republicans that aren't fiscally conservative,
but how dare you bring that up? That's your argument. Do you
think that you're able to support someone who's like not fiscally
conservative on like one single point, but then if you Okay,
do you think that Yes. Yes, that's exactly what I'm saying. Here
is like one point of many that Donald Trump violates of being
like a conservative, right? That's I absolutely think that the
previous statement that you made is what I agree. That you're
not selling out because you're not Let me finish my point. Let
me finish my point. Let me finish Let me finish my point. Let
me finish my point. Let me Let me finish my point, right? And
so yes, I I think the guy finally leaves here. Okay. I think
he finally leaves. I think it's absurd to call someone a cancer
to the Republican Party because you're not a real conservative
and the first thing you say is fiscal conservatism and I point
out yeah, actually you support people that aren't fiscally conservative
and I don't think that makes you a cancer to the party, right?
And you're like oh well, you know, clearly just supporting someone
that's not one thing doesn't mean you're a sellout or cancers.
Yes, totally
He left. Hey, good effort, sir. Did a great job. Hold on, man.
It's his bedtime, I guess. Mommy I'm going to hear what he's
saying after I just turn in.
That's unfortunate. I was having a good
I guess. I think you fell into a red black hole. Yeah. Just saying.
That was so
First of all, I didn't know you turn up like that. That was great.
I had I enjoyed the [__] out of that. That was fun.
Yeah, I enjoyed it as well. I did not expect the mental I didn't
think it would actually be that bad. I I Rob knows reputation
precedes him. Are Are they just telling this guy that he
That's that's [__] up to bring a child on stream
and then just gaslight them like this.
Debater, but like holy this whole
I I didn't expect it to be this bad.
I'm kind of twisted on why he went straight to Destiny.
The thing is he has like these Wasn't it Wasn't it literally
who's your who's a example of a conservative and this guy said
Counter-Points?
I mean it's pretty obvious that's where you're going to go.
Rob Norse made plenty of criticisms of Counter-Points along those
exact lines.
Not shocking that he go that way. points out, right? So he's
usually dealing with like the leftists and then like oh you're
liberal leftist and you support like Destiny. So that being said,
you're Where does he Somebody's putting him up Somebody's putting
him up to I already said that.
to attacking He's attacking Destiny's funding. I've heard him
go after sponsors
for Destiny a lot of times. I don't I want I'm curious who's
behind that. I've heard him go after sponsors for Destiny a lot
of times. I wonder who's behind that. Is this just talking about
progressive victory like political funding going to
I I don't Rob has good points there, but there are like points
you could make.
Destiny's drunk. He sounds drunk. Do you reckon that's an Andrew
diss coming from Andrew Wilson directly, or did he just choose
Destiny as a target? I I would like to address his question,
um if you guys will allow me, on why he's worthy of being targeted.
Okay. But
whatever, man. Okay. He is being targeted right now, I
Destiny. Destiny?
>> Yeah, I think he's under
Bro, I had no I had no idea this is where this was going.
I don't know, investigation for lack of better word. I'm not
a legal ease heavy guy, but
I've only seen one of Destiny's shows, and it was like they were
making fun of somebody with mental health issues. So, I I don't
really have any other opinions on that. Well, the issue is when
you say people should be afraid to engage in political
discourse or action or XY Z.
But how how long can Rob cry about that line? It's a It's insane.
He needs to He needs to pull pull the pull like I said, pull
his panties out of and move on.
a live streamer said a thing that was like medium aggressive,
right? It wasn't even a proper threat. Well, do you have you
heard his
recollection on what it
would it be justified if his parents were at a MAGA rally? Cuz
I think his parents are conservative. I may be wrong there, I
don't know. I don't follow him closely. No. But
I believe he said that if if your parents were at because he
said the same thing about uh Okay, I have no idea if this ever
changes up here. It becomes like more interesting. I don't think
I don't think this Sarah person like almost says anything.
That's That's so funny that Rob went after her specifically over
this review of his stream. >> sorry. Yeah. I mean, it's
You can't help it, you're tarded, but whatever. >> What
did you do to him? He's so submissive to you out the gate. I
don't know. Sarah's awesome. You know what? I I consider Sarah
like a contributing member of the community that's a mother,
and I respect that, bro. Sue you. Have you ever had Someone needs
to mommy him. Have you ever had Have you Have you ever had like
a big
[__] in your mouth and not Have we all taken one
out of that?
Right, Sarah? You're right in the middle of it. I'm always in
the middle of it. It's my job to be in the middle. You're doing
a great job at this point. Your market value is going up like
crazy. I mean, god damn it. Should I go public so I can invest
on Robinhood for your podcast? Mhm. She's not a cow. What the
[__] Bro, this is this like
I I can't believe Sarah apparently messaged Rob to like give
him some
But I I actually don't understand why he got so frustrated with
her specifically. So, if you remember, Sarah's the person that
Rob calls out as like somebody who's like, "Don't give me advice
if I'm you. You have no talent shit." He kind of blew up on her.
I wonder if Rob's got I wonder if Rob's good. I wonder if he's
got some [__] going on.
I don't see why he was going so hard on
I don't see why he's so upset. But we got a stream the next day,
okay? This is
The power that the power of the panelverse has me on tilt. I'm
guessing Rob talks about it pretty early on here.
He's going to explain why he was so tilted, why he was so upset.
Let's give it a quick
Host Rob Noer Show, Normal American. Great to be here. Most of
the people that would normally watch me at 10:00 are probably
watching my friend Andrew Wilson right now, but
um I figured I'd come on a little this
and just talk a little about the drama of the day, get it behind
me, and then
move forward with the politics, the culture, the debates, the
this, the thats, the others
as we go forward, so.
Did Pisco talking taking Rob's crash out, or was it just the
Twitter post? Did Pisco talking Oh, did he talk I have no idea
if he talked about >> Let's talk about the old drama.
Oh, no, I'm not going to join on Andrew's show. Uh I know that
he's talking about it. I was downstairs watching it. Uh I thought
he Oh, wait. Andrew Wilson had a comments?
Oh Oh, wait. I'll never find an Andrew Wilson. Does Andrew Wilson
leave his VODs up on Rumble now?
Hold on. There's got to be somewhere you can watch the live Andrew
Wilson VODs,
Crucible? Crucible?
2 days ago, something with Rob lives.
Again, something with Rob. I wonder if I can find any footage
of Andrew Wilson talking about it. We'll see.
We'll see if we can look in the background here real quick. >> Andrew
was saying about me, but um uh thanks, Orthodox. I appreciate
it. What's up, Naughty German? Thanks for the five bucks. So,
we covered this a lot today. I heard the end of Sarah's baby
10,000. It's very We'll talk about We'll talk about Andrew's
uh takes on this. Um and more about >> going to talk about
it. power of the
The fear that Oh my gosh.
The fear. The power of the panelverse >> Oh, [__]
Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's two There's two different videos here. Hold on. But you
know, women, they just don't seem to understand >> going
to pull this up so you guys can see the thumbnails as well. You
[__] >> I searched for this for the past day
or something, okay?
This is um Hoping Christ, the channel Hoping Christ with this
guy's got this like Pepe sitting in a maybe a Pipo sitting in
a chair. Over 300 Andrew Wilson clips.
Andrew Wilson if this rates Sarah the Raging Tomato for betraying
Rob Noer.
Rob Noer, part two.
We got part one and part two.
This This is growing.
Rob Noer, Andrew Wilson, 3:00 a.m. friends. The Raging Tomato
[__] up. Friendship, faith, family, God. Andrew Wilson
squashed the Raging Tomato into ketchup after backstabbing Rob
Noer, part one, part three, part two.
Bro, this is like big views. These people are all over this [__]
Did she even say anything?
I don't know.
I literally Oh, people are abandoning her channel, minus 2,000
subs in 12 hours. I I don't even think Listen, I know Rob's mad.
I don't think Rob would be that mad. I doubt Rob's that mad that
he's like, "Guys, you all need to unsub from her channel and
this bitch." I feel like Rob would feel bad about that after
seeing this happen.
I will give his We'll give his stream a a watch here.
I feel like Rob wouldn't even advocate for that. It's like, "Oh,
no. Like, I was having a bad day, man." By the way, thanks everyone
that's a new sub, you know? I'm getting a lot of new subs. I
assume all channels tonight are picking up a bunch of subs. You
know, everyone that's streaming picking up a probably a bunch
of subs. Uh
I'll probably be on for an hour or two. What's up, Project VOPD?
Yeah, I Project VOP. What I call VOPD.
But we'll talk about some of that. First, I would like to explain
a little bit about my evening.
Before we go there, I was streaming late into the day, later
than normal, and then as you know, my son had his
fall fest
Halloween
uh party at his school, and it was one of the best
I'm sort of on the Twitch politics I need I need the drama, Rob.
I need the drama. Put the drama in the bag. In the bag, little
bro, okay? I need the drama. >> I have one thing going
for me. Um well, I I got a couple, but I'm a good debater. That's
Andrew's a good debater.
Andrew's one of the best debaters, but he's also
an amazing planner, coordinator.
Okay. >> He He has an eye for building a community like
I've never seen. The I have everything that my channel is right
when it comes to the growth that I've received since I've gone
full-time, everything is literally either directly modeled from
Andrew's channel, or
through him telling me to do things that are slightly different
in person, telling me what to do.
So, um
He went full-time? Yeah, Rob I think has gone full-time, yes.
Oh God, that's horrible. Why do you think that's
I will for Rob. I have no doubt that Rob has like Rob has like
a hundred times more earning potential as a YouTube creator than
he does being a home care nurse. Or whatever. I don't know if
it's home care specifically, but he's like a nurse. He He helps
special needs people take care of themselves, right? Rob Rob
makes infinitely more from YouTube than he does from his real
job. His real job is is totally consequential, by the way. I
don't even mean that to His His job's like super important. People
willing to take care of of the infirm and the the sick in society
are incredibly important. So, I I actually I'm not judging him
in any way. I'm saying that he himself just has he's a very good
he's Sorry, he's a reasonably good debater. Pretty good.
I think he's just got way more earning potential doing this.
I owe 90% of my channel's success to Andrew.
I toiled away for years. Andrew used to tell me he'd be like,
"Listen, dude. What are you doing? Like, you're getting blacklisted.
These They're screwing with you. You're getting mass reported."
I didn't believe it. All of a sudden, bam. 13 videos removed.
Two community strikes within a 10-minute period. Over nothing.
He said, "You got to be careful. You got to be careful who you're
going on with. These They're trying to take you down in this
Twitch cuz I was sort of on the Twitch politics sphere. I'm naive,
man. I'm doing the You know, while I was toiling away at a home
health care job, Andrew took a chance on himself, which is another
thing that I think is so impressive
that he really took a chance on himself, and Bro, yeah, but this
was like a long time ago. I'm surprised Rob is like arriving
at this now. I Maybe Maybe I just don't watch his streams. I
started noticing this about Andrew Wilson like a year and a half
ago when he had like his first 2 months of like massive sub and
revenue growth. I was like, oh, I see exactly why he was going
on whatever, why he was interacting with the manosphere. I see
the exact strategy here. Yeah, it was a master stroke, totally
paid off. He's making insane money now. Very cool. And now built
what he has and he's one of the biggest
streamers, conservative and I don't mean biggest monetarily,
I don't mean biggest viewers, I mean biggest in that
even people that you would say arguably have more of a reach
than Andrew are literally
taking Andrew's philosophy and talking points and running with
it. Watch Matt Walsh talk about trans issues or something. That's
Andrew. Talk about feminism. That's Andrew. He is saying stuff
in the space
and has been saying it for 3 years that people now are just willing
to say in the mainstream. Andrew Wilson one day, while I'm doing
home health care working 100 hours a week, I'm not joking you.
By the way, I did work 100-hour weeks because
I had to be at work 24/7 at least half the week. I did home health
care with adults with disabilities.
But even when I got home, I had to do trainings. I was the supervisor
of the house, well, team lead, de facto supervisor. So, I ended
up doing all these trainings and stuff. So, even though I didn't
get paid for my sleep shift, so if I was there three or four
nights, that was 32 hours I didn't get paid cuz it was sleep
shift. But if you look at my pay slips, I'm making like [__]
85 hours. That's how much
So, Rob is working insane amount. Um apparently, in terms of
this month for YouTube revenue, okay, YouTube super chat revenue,
all right? In October,
Normal American with Rob Noer is on Dean Withers' tail. He is
going to take Dean Withers' silver medal and shove it up his
ass, okay? Probably not cuz he's conservative and not gay, but
Rob's making bank, it looks like, okay? So, everybody who's like,
oh, that was a terrible decision, Rob just made like half Rob
probably just made a third of his yearly income, nearly, okay?
Maybe a quarter of his yearly income in 1 month.
Like this is almost de facto not a bad strategy. Everybody needs
home care workers and [__] like that. Rob can always
go back to that job. I promise you Rob will be able to get back
into that line of work immediately.
This line of work, he's got an opportunity here and if he seizes
on it and makes a lot of money doing it, he can set his family
up. Anyway, we
with Rob Noer.
>> Long story short, not to get into it, I I would stream
when my my sleep shift would start and
I had a really bad day at work.
the gentleman that I take care of primarily was was having some
rough health outcomes and it looked as if I would probably
not be able to continue that line of work any uh because the
nature of it is if you do health care and the person that you're
taking care of uh needs
a different level of care that I can't provide, then that's it.
So, I was bummed. Okay. So, Rob having some health issues that
are going to prevent him from doing this job. That kind of sucks.
Having some physical issues. >> but I did a stream and
say like, hey man, prayers to my
Okay. Hi, Perry. Hi, Perry. my client that I take care of cuz
the the health is looking very poor. And I was like, I don't
know what's going to happen like with my job and we'll make it
work. 5 minutes after I get off stream, Andrew texts me. Hey
man, you got time for a call? I said, yeah. What's going on?
So, I talked to him. Here's the thing, there's certain things
that you can't talk about on air that you can talk about behind
the scenes. So, I give him a little more details that I wouldn't
be comfortable talking about on air, just the specifics of my
job, etc.
He's like, come work for the Crucible.
And I was like, I don't know, man, like it He's like, how much
would it cost?
And I was like, man, my number one duty in the world is to provide
for my wife and for my son. And my lesson Hey, look, it's Modern
Man loss again. How you doing, bud? Hey, you guys did a great
job last night. You guys did good. Great job. Modern Man, he
Modern Man's one of the guys that called in Bro, he's gone up
like How much has he gone up here? I feel like he's gone up like
60 bucks since he started talking.
Last night the troll army. He did great.
You guys really accomplished your goals, man. The Panel Verse
You guys crushed it. You guys crushed it, Panel Verse. You did
it, man. Uh
Loving it.
You guys really did it. Anyways, uh This
This is going to be some funny [__]
Oh, I see, Perry. All right. This is I feel like this could actually
blow up into something. Cuz Andrew Wilson did set up a lot of
this this like streamer
He I think he set up a couple of these panel shows by going on
them and supporting them, right? So, he kind of runs This is
his little orbit where he runs everything and if if these videos
are actually accurate and he like totally [__] on
her, that's going to shake things up there a lot. Anyway. I'll
finish my story and then I'll deal with the trolls. Um and he
was like, yeah, well, let's work something out and we did and
I've been working for the Crucible ever since, but not only that,
um I was able to stream full time and Andrew used to tell me
like, dude, you could make it as a full-time streamer. I'd be
like, nah, you're just saying that because you're a friend, you're
being nice. But he's right. We'll get that donogo crushed again
tonight for Hassan for the for Hassan chair, I mean Rob. Okay.
There he is. Bro, I All I know for sure is this is like the reason
I lamented not just being able to like politically grift cuz
I felt like I moved away from any I probably was never close
to these people in terms of conservatism, but I could have argued
their points and been like close-ish, but I just I feel like
I can't lie about, you know, how I feel about things, how I feel
about political
But if I could, man, oh, conservatives pay so much in super chats.
It's crazy. As member of the Panel Verse, yes. And that changed
my life. It's nuts. If
if tomorrow my channel got demonetized and for whatever reason
Andrew was like, hey Rob, it's been real, but I've decided my
wife and our family are we're moving to the and living off the
grid the rest of our
Peace. See you. You know, sorry I can't pay you anymore. He'd
never do that, but if that was the case, he's changed my life.
I would never forget forget it.
Just having these past 6 months to do things like be able to
go to T-ball games with my son, to be home every
to be able to read to my son every night when I literally my
son was growing up without me. That's what was happening. That
I will never forget that. I will always have Andrew's back. I
don't give a [__] no matter what.
Now, here's the thing, though.
I'm not the only one that Andrew's helped out in significant
ways. And Andrew is the exact type of guy I've said this for
3 years. So many people portray themselves as these nice, friendly
people online and then they're pieces of [__] they
can't wait to stab you in the
Andrew's a guy who portrays that people at least pretend is portrayed
as this
terrible character who's the nicest, friendliest in the world
behind the scenes. I've said that for years. I was like, it's
like he inverted it. Everyone else is, oh, you're the best, you're
great. Can you do me a favor? Can you I've always I've always
made this point and a lot of people get really mad at me that
I think Andrew Wilson could be like on in personal in a personal
sense like a good person. I can tell that he's not like a good
person always. I can tell that he's a like total [__]
Um his whole thing with Tree, I know I I like Tree. I'm friends
with Tree. I'll probably never be friends with him personally,
but
like I've always thought like person interpersonally, it seemed
like he was all right. And I think Rob kind of backs that up.
Now, some of the things they
difficult to see it and I understand why. He do this panel for
me and then they're [__] you behind the scenes. >> Not
Andrew. Andrew used to give me [__] Rob, why don't
you you know, would you be interested in going on some bigger
shows? Sure, then why aren't you? I don't know anyone. Why didn't
you ask me? Cuz I don't want to bother you. What the [__]
your problem? You want to get on bigger show? Let me know. Let's
do it. All of that was before tonight.
And what Andrew did tonight
uh was probably one of the kindest things that anyone has ever
said about me. Not only talking me up to his audience, but unquestionably
like, yeah, [__] it, I got your back. That's it.
Andrew says I'm a better debater than him. That's not Accelerati,
I swore off all Kaya coverage, okay? We have stopped the Kaya
coverage. I saw the clip. Um certainly sounds like you hear a
click there. Seems like she reacts.
Unfortunately, there's no way to go through that. I would love
to look it for more context. I can't look at the clip without
looking for more context,
you know, uh certainly looks bad,
That's what I can say. Not true. There are certain topics that
I can debate better than Andrew.
I was hanging out with Andrew a couple weeks ago and I bet I
sat there silently and listened to him talk to me about the Orthodox
faith for probably 3 hours. There is zero chance that I would
have
remote chance in a philosophical debate or religious debate with
Andrew. There's some political normative politics debate that
I'd probably beat Andrew. Like if we're debating like
tariffs or something like that, maybe, but anything with There's
no click. Uh the clip I watched, there was definitely a click
there. Like I hear an audible
it comes to the philosophical. I just
believe it or not, I am just a dumb redneck. I don't really think
that way. I think just like
I don't understand philosophy that much. Um since we're this
late in the stream, I'm thinking what I might do is save a little
bit of this. I might watch further in, but I think a lot of this
is going to have to do with Andrew Wilson as well, and we could
continue on with this maybe tomorrow.
You know? Wait, 8 hours 20 minutes, and
yeah, I'm thinking tomorrow we could we could continue on with
this stuff. Um we'll continue continue on with this maybe any
Emiru updates. The Miz thing I don't think is I I can look at
it. I don't know if there's as much there as I had hoped. Oh,
hold on. Let me see.
Let's let's cover that real quick, okay? On the way before I
continue on with this. Let's cover that real quick cuz I don't
know if there's anything special there, okay? I don't know. We'll
Emiru will be dropping a nuke on Mizkif when returning back home
from TwitchCon, all right? This feels connected Asmongold calling
out Mizkif for lying on why streamers don't want to collab with
him. That's not why people don't want to collaborate with Miz.
It doesn't have a lot to do with Tectone either. He's lying.
Spill the tea. I have a feeling I might not have to. We remember
this one, right? We remember this. Asmongold, I have a feeling
I might not have to. Remember how performative he was?
for the [__] bike all the way to the damn TwitchCon
last minute. Let's listen to this one more time. Burger Planet's
going to pick us up in his van soon with something disabled chicken
in the back of the seat. I want to go back. This was in July
8th. Guys don't know
Asmongold saying he'll call out Mizkif's
>> Oh man, I guarantee you bro like they've been crashing
out on each other for a while. People are going to be saying
some [__] about each other in a bit. I I I will I
will say this. If any of these guys drop receipts on each other,
and anybody lies or misrepresents
anything, I will be there to correct the record. Well, here I
am. That's not why people don't want to collaborate with Miz.
Huh? It has nothing to do with it.
And he knows that.
Watch watch the smug.
Nothing to do with it. And also,
it doesn't have a lot to do with Tectone
He's lying.
I don't know why he would say that. >> You see You see
him throw Dude,
you see Bro, look at him throw that eyebrow. Look that that is
a that's like nearly a red flag eyebrow raise, okay?
Like we we got to kick this guy Dude, when did this guy get to
be such a showman that he throws the eyebrow like that? I don't
know why he would say
I don't know why he would do that. Now, I have not said anything
about this at
I have not gone into this
on any level, but that's not why.
Dude. Dude. Dude.
Dude, you get the you get the Twitter player up over his face.
Dude, look at this Look at the smugness, okay? Look at
Look at this.
Imagine the Twitter player wasn't there blocking it, okay? This
whole time. And then we'll we'll watch up until he delivers the
I have a feeling I won't I won't have to. Watch there. It's not
even close to why. Spill the tea. I don't think I'm going to
have to. I've got a feeling Oh, I've got a feeling I might not
have to.
son of a [__] This son of a [__]
Anyway, so that's that's I think
I think Best Friend is in the same schizosphere I am, where I
immediately was like, "Oh, I'm feeling this connection. I'm feeling
this Miz nuke might be coming." Let's see what clips he felt
And the last thing that I want to say is um
I didn't really get a chance to talk about it because of, you
know, all the things that were happening, but
um I kind of wanted to apologize for
uh some people were talking about the clip of me
Here we go. getting kind of emotional at the end of the RV trip.
Yeah, everyone's
sometimes going through stuff that not everyone knows about.
Uh for me in
this has been
I've never talked about this cuz I never like wanted to bring
it to stream or anything like that. But, honestly, this has been
a really hard year for me. Uh honestly, it's been a really hard
like 2 years. Um I've been carrying a lot of really heavy burdens,
and um
I feel like I'm the luckiest streamer in the world that um I've
gotten to go as far as I have.
And um but I have people around me that really do support me
and want to do stuff with me.
And then I get I get to do cool stuff like this, and then I can
afford to do
Um so,
yeah, I'm just really grateful, but I always try to just stream
with a smile and keep going. There's been times the past 2 years
that
well, everyone knows I do long intros. I don't want people to
think this is every time. Sometimes I cry during my intro. I
Listen, Emmy, that's okay. Sometimes I cry during my intro. I
don't, but I'll just say anything right now to make you stop
crying, okay? But, there's been times where like
I wanted to stream, but I would be like crying in my intro.
And uh but every time, you know, I started stream, I felt completely
fine after
You know, like I'm just so happy that I you know what what I
I do so much, and that I can do so many different things. Games
and stuff like this, and I'm I'm glad that people want to watch
all of it even if, you know, it's not necessarily their cup of
tea.
And um
yeah, I you know, when I I first met I feel like we've gone way
through everything we needed from this clip, but I wonder if
Best Friend caught something I didn't. Jesus. This isn't true.
This isn't true. That was one time
>> Emily and Sedona all around the same time, I think,
3 years ago. And from the start, I really wanted to be friends
with all three of them, but for some reason back then, it felt
like Oh. Oh.
Wait, there is one more thing. Back then it felt like someone
something didn't want want to let that happen, right? Somebody
Oh, I forgot what >> reason back then, it felt like so
many
were so far out of reach, and like I I couldn't be friends with
Even though they were so nice, I just I couldn't be friends with
them. Oh, but um now I feel like, you know, we're really all
friends, and we really all care about each other, and like a
lot of it, you know, is for stream, but I'm just really grateful
for the way that things are now. And things are honestly better
than I ever thought that they could be.
And sometimes
there's things in your life or people in your life that, you
know, they're not maybe they're not good for you, and
sometimes maybe you have to make those
to take those people out of your life so you can make room for
the people that are right for your life.
Uh I missed I I thought this was earlier in the stream. Holy
Yes, okay. So, we've got this part that I thought we went through,
right? Sometimes you got to get rid of people from your life.
You got to take people out of your life so that
you know, you know those people, guys? The people who take things
away from So, take those people out of your life so you can make
room for the people that are right for your life. Mizkif just
wasn't right for her life, and and perhaps removing him allowed
the right people to come in.
Now, we we speculated that this clip was about Mizkif Mizkif
from before. We didn't know for sure, right? We speculated. It
seems like Best Friend is also going to speculate along with
us, all right?
Hold on. Hold on. Uh live Miz react We're going to a live Miz
reaction to this clip, okay? Miz is not doing well. It's not
It's not a great time, okay?
This is not This is not good. All right, he's watching it all
burn down again.
If he He was ready to end it last time. Wait until he sees this
time, okay? Wait until he sees it this time. It's not good. No,
for real, I hope I hope this isn't about Mizkif, but I That was
where my schizosphere divinations led me as well was this seems
to be Oh boy, some big Mizkif drama brewing. you know, and I
also think it's important to never give up. This whole
I've taken a couple breaks, but um
I never wanted to quit
or or stop going. I was like, I have to keep going no matter
what
because I'm so lucky, and because it's what makes me happy.
You can never give up no matter how people treat you or what
you're going through because you'll be able to look back and
be proud on yourself even if it's hard in the
Um Wow. That [__] kind of slipped out, but
there's a lot of things that
I haven't wanted to talk about
that I think I will probably be talking
>> It's the same smug face. Okay, I'm sold.
got his stupid smug grin on again, okay? That's what it was.
I didn't watch the Asmongold reaction to this. If I'd seen this
smug face again, I would have known, "Oh, he's definitely He's
laughing at Mizkif right now." Mizkif, he is laughing at you.
Do you see this with the Twitter bar halfway through his
He's laughing at you.
Breathing is hard. He's laughing at you, Mizkif. Will you let
Asmongold have the last laugh, Mizkif? uh when I get home from
TwitchCon. So,
just want to let you guys know about >> Oh!
Oh my god. Hold on. When I get home from TwitchCon, watch his
face change.
just want to let you guys know about that. Yeah, thank you guys
for this Okay, I didn't go back far enough, but you see it. You
see the smugness,
okay? As she says she's got some [__] to reveal.
Oh, that's 100% about Mizkif. I see I [__] up not
watching the Asmongold vod. I would have picked that [__]
up immediately. I've never seen this guy look happier than when
he is secretly hinting at the downfall of Mizkif, okay? This
guy This guy I I see him totally stone-faced when a mother and
child are separated by ICE, okay? By Immigration and Customs
Enforcement. Totally stone-faced. No emotion. Suddenly, he's
talking about a woman, you know, leveling Mizkif's entire existence.
He's never seemed happier in his entire life.
Dude, streaming does [__] to people. sports I don't
think she's going to say If you think this is crazy, just wait
for the next one. Oh my, never mind. It wasn't even It wasn't
even a little controversial. Yeah, okay.
Oh boy. Miz
Do we get a wellness check on Mizkif? Is Mizkif okay? Did Mizkif
stream today? Is he Is he okay? Is he all right? Cuz holy [__]
This This seems terrifying.
You got to You got to feel like Mizkif's totally done, right?
Why would they be fronting like this? Why would they be fronting
and acting like he's going to totally go down and then it's just
nothing? Can someone check his ring cam?
Ah, I saw you mention Mitch Jones, Sherry, okay? Maybe this is,
you know, Mitch behind the stream behind the
pulling strings like a puppet master, okay? You want to beat
the [__] out of me, Mizkif? You want to beat the
[__] out of me? I'll destroy everything. I'll destroy
everything. I'll destroy everything you have.
Mitch Jones W, okay? He won again.
Incredible incredible stuff. All right, I'm going to rate out.
Oh, looks like Chud's live. I don't know what the [__]
he's doing. He's watching something racist. He's being racist.
He's doing his thing. All right, all right, Chud. And I'll be
back tomorrow, guys. Have a good night. Yeah, I've heard there's
a lot of good IRL reactions from TwitchCon to go over, so I'll
try to find some of those for tomorrow, okay? Have a good night,
guys.
We'll talk to you later. Bye-bye.